dos de los o perdones más estudiados son
el operante erp y el operón lac y lo que
quiero que hagamos en este vídeo es
enfocarnos en el operante erp que es
esencial para la producción de
triptófano triptófano que posiblemente
reconozcas como un aminoácido y el
triptófano como la mayoría de los
aminoácidos son esenciales para la
creación de los polipéptidos las
proteínas que utilizamos en nuestro
cuerpo y en este caso no vamos a estar
hablando del cuerpo humano vamos a estar
hablando de algo que está en el cuerpo
humano
vamos a hablar acerca de la e.coli es 1
perón que está en la école y que es
parte del genoma de la e coli y en este
diagrama por la forma en que está
dibujado se encuentra justo aquí y sólo
como un recordatorio 1 pero no es una
combinación de un conjunto de genes
junto con las secuencias reguladoras de
adn para ese conjunto de genes
particularmente tenemos el promotor y
tenemos al operador por aquí
el promotor es donde la arn polimerasa
se une y comienza el proceso de
transcripción el operador es donde el
represor se une y esto va a ser esencial
para que podamos comprender cómo
funciona el operante erp y para que
codifican estos genes estos genes
codifican para enzimas que se utilizan
en la síntesis de triptófano y siempre
me sorprende que las enzimas se puedan
utilizar para generar lo que
esencialmente son moléculas que son
mucho más pequeñas que las mismas
enzimas
de hecho las enzimas implicadas se
componen de aminoácidos y se utilizan
para hacer aminoácidos particulares así
los tcp
se ve ya una vez que se transcriben en
mensajero y luego son traducidos en los
ribosomas estas enzimas se pueden
utilizar para crear triptófano para la
biosíntesis de triptófano así que vamos
a pensar en
funciona esto si la coli está en un
entorno con baja concentración de
triptófano nuestra e.coli necesita del
triptófano como componente fundamental
para sus proteínas así que en ese
escenario es lógico que en un ambiente
con baja concentración de triptófano la
arn polimerasa se una al promotor y
comience el proceso de transcripción
transcribe a estos cinco genes en rn
mensajero que puede ser traducido a
estas enzimas y entonces habría más vía
síntesis de triptófano tiene lógica que
queremos crear triptófano si nos
encontramos en un entorno que no tiene
una gran cantidad de triptófano pero qué
ocurre si hay una gran cantidad de
triptófano en el entorno bueno si
tenemos una gran cantidad de algo
alrededor
normalmente no desperdiciamos mucha
energía en crear más de ese algo debemos
tener en cuenta que todos los organismos
que existen hoy en día son productos de
miles de millones de años de evolución y
han aprendido a ser muy cuidadosos
o los organismos que son seleccionados
tienden a ser los que no desperdician
sus recursos de ese modo cuando hay
triptófano alrededor probablemente el
organismo no desee que ocurra esta
transcripción así que tiene lógica que
tal vez el triptófano esté actuando como
un correo pre sort para un represor para
una enzima represora que se uniría al
operador y bloquearía la arn polimerasa
impidiendo así la transcripción y eso es
exactamente lo que sucede así que si
estamos en un entorno con alta
concentración de triptófano y el
triptófano en realidad no se ve como
estos pequeños cuadriláteros amarillos
pero esto es solo para poder visualizar
todo esto mejor la arn polimerasa
tampoco se ve así el represor de erp
tampoco se parece a esta figura de hecho
los invito a buscar estas moléculas por
internet para que sepan cómo se ven en
realidad son fascinantes pero cuando se
tiene una gran cantidad de triptófano el
triptófano puede actuar como un corre
preso
go red pre sol
se puede unir al represor de rpp
activando lo por lo que va a cambiar su
configuración para que luego se pueda
unir al operador en el operan y una vez
que está unido al operador
entonces la arn polimerasa ya no puede
continuar con la transcripción como se
puede ver se trata de un asa de
retroalimentación muy valiosa o ni
siquiera es necesariamente una
retroalimentación si nos encontramos en
un entorno con una gran cantidad de
triptófano no necesitamos crear más
triptófano y si no tenemos triptófano
alrededor entonces
el represor no será co reprimido
podríamos decir y entonces se creara el
triptófano ahora el triptófano es algo
muy interesante porque el control de la
transcripción no es el único lugar donde
se tiene algún tipo de asa de
retroalimentación o tipo de situación
condicional se puede obtener también la
inhibición por retroalimentación directa
entre las proteínas y
aparte no está relacionada con la
transcripción y este diagrama es algo
abstracto pero este es un precursor de
triptófano y digamos que la enzima 1 lo
convierte en el precursor 2 la enzima 2
lo convierte en el precursor 3 y la
enzima 3 lo convierte en triptófano
estamos teniendo inhibición por
retroalimentación directa donde el
triptófano se puede unir o interactuar
con la enzima 1 aquí de modo que ésta ya
no puede actuar tan eficientemente
convirtiendo el precursor 1 en el
precursor 2 por lo que este es el
clásico mecanismo de la inhibición por
retroalimentación
inhibición
x
retro
y alimentación
en este vídeo estamos hablando de opero
nes y regulación de genes pero es
importante saber que la regulación de la
creación de triptófano no solo ocurre a
nivel de transcripción y no vamos a ver
ese tema en este vídeo es un tema un
poco más avanzado pero también está la
regulación de biosíntesis de triptófano
a través de un proceso llamado
atenuación que no afecta el inicio de la
transcripción sino que afecta cómo se
completan las cosas evita que se
complete el proceso de biosíntesis pero
las formas de regulación más comunes son
las que acabamos de describir aquí donde
el triptófano actúa como un correo pre
sort del represor de erp y también
tenemos la inhibición por
retroalimentación que una vez más no es
realmente un tipo de regulación génica
pero se puede ver como el producto de
este proceso puede volver al inicio e
inhibir una de las primeras enzimas